all right diamond diamond where are you
from originally where'd you grow up I'm
from Columbus Ohio
and tell me about your family growing up
um you know I had a great life growing
up you know my dad he was a veteran
um my brother though he was in and out
of prison he was always on the streets
you know hustling because we didn't have
much money growing up so I mean that was
about it but I mean I I grew up with the
motive to like get money Hustle by any
means and do what I got to do so where
do you think he got that from just being
on the streets of Columbus North side
but you had you had good parents yeah
but you know at the same time when you
don't have money that's what makes the
motive to like I gotta do this that and
the third
and I remember growing up we would Rob
drug dealers we would car hop cars I
mean we would take it as far as my
brother he would even Rob the hostess
truck because we didn't have any
groceries in the house and he had to get
us groceries so is it your brother that
kind of LED you into the streets
um I guess in a sense it was more like a
team effort you know what I mean but I
got out of the streets and so did he so
you know it people people come out
in uh how for you in school
um I went to I'm actually in college so
I got my GED
and I went to college like I just
started college like a year ago
um yeah I'm 25. yeah but your GED means
you didn't really continue with school
no like high school was way too much
drama I was way more focused on like
partying at the time doing Molly Ecstasy
LSD
um I was very into drugs in high school
so like
school was the last thing school was
just like a place for me to go like talk
about oh my God that party last weekend
it was crazy and it just wasn't me and
when I turned 18 they can no longer
arrest you for truancy and I was just
like I'm out of here there was nothing
for me left there
and you describe yourself as a sex
addict yes
I do describe myself as a sex addict and
I'm not like most sex addicts that
people see you know they think oh she's
probably [ __ ] like 100 people all
types of people no I'm very conservative
um I keep a small circle
but you like sex I like sex all the time
I like all type of men I like all types
of decks I don't discriminate you know
so
um it's something
sex addiction is something that I felt
like saved my life because in a sense
when I was younger I would do drugs and
I would you know at first I was addicted
to Molly then I was addicted to LSD but
you can't really even be addicted to
that it was more of just a mindset that
I I like this I want to get high all the
time I want to do this and you know the
fun started running out and you know I
could feel my brain slowly deteriorating
so I started to gamble to get my high
because everybody likes a little
adrenaline they like a little rush you
know what I'm saying and I started
gambling and the money started to run
real dry with that so I had to step back
from the casino and I had to think of
something that was free I mean at the
time when I was on drugs I was dating a
drug dealer so my drugs were free but
once I'm out of the Trap and not dating
him anymore how was I supposed to
support my lifestyle you know what I'm
saying
so that's when sex addiction came about
it's free it's easy and it gives you
kind of like a a euphoric feel just like
you would get from everything else is
are there are all these addictions
interchangeable oh definitely you can
interchange any addiction and it's
almost better to you know a lot of
people want to focus on like I gotta
quit this I gotta quit this don't quit
it replace it
with something maybe healthier yeah do
something maybe healthier more
affordable
and you know and even actually the first
time I had sex it was actually due to my
addiction because you know I was 13 and
I was addicted to cigarettes and I was
on Kick and I was in these group chats
for smokers it was like single smokers
and stuff like that so I was talking to
Men on there and I found a guy and I
lost my virginity for a carton Newport
menthols so
and I actually I really liked him at the
time he was a really good guy his name
was Billy
all kinds of random Partners you're just
more I'm more focused on the ones that
been there because they know me they
know what I like you know do you like
sex how often I like sex every day I
want to wake up to it well that I mean I
think a lot of people probably had sex
every day multiple times a day okay
okay come on now
you could make money at this yeah you
can like as a female yeah I always
thought about being a prostitute but
then I was always like ah I don't know
like diseases and then like honestly I'm
way too lazy and I feel like I like to
like someone and have them wine and die
me first like you at least gotta take me
out to dinner first I'm not an easy day
you know like
at least and I feel like well
prostitution is good because you get the
money up front and it's great you know
I'm all for transactional sex but it's
just too much drama for me
and are you working currently I am
working I got a bunch of different
hustles going on okay
it's not like you had any traumatic
event in your childhood
no you know that's the thing is a lot of
people want to assume that addictions
and bad habits come from traumatic
things that happen and you know your
childhood which it like a lot of the
times it is but a lot of the other times
it's that people for one it's not even
an emotional thing they just like to
party and that's what it kind of came
down for me I wasn't doing drugs because
I was depressed I wanted to party I want
to do you know I want to have a good
time that was it and that's what it
makes it kind of like tricky when you
you know when you like talk to somebody
else with addiction because there's a
lot of people that really really go
through a lot of things and that's why
they are the way they are and me you
know when it came to my addiction it all
just came down to that Soul factor I
want to turn up is it just adrenaline
it's the adrenaline it's the feeling you
know I'm an adrenaline junkie you know
like I have an addictive personality I
can get addicted to anything and that's
the same with every other person I mean
a lot of average people they're quick to
judge somebody because you know they're
addicted to this and they're addicted to
that but average people drink coffee
every day do I judge them for their
addiction average people drink water do
we want to call that an addiction
I think like addiction the term is kind
of thrown around you know do a little
too much
You could argue that a sex addiction is
not necessarily that bad it's definitely
not that bad and I think it's something
I think sex should be more embraced
what's wrong with it you know Jesus had
sex Mary and Joseph had sex I mean even
as a Christian sex is okay you know like
so I feel like anyone the Judgment I see
online about it all the time is kind of
just like whoa and like the Judgment
prostitutes get all the time is kind of
like whoa and I feel like people who are
jealous of like prostitutes and stuff
like that are probably just mad because
their husbands probably slept with a
prostitute so I feel like people in the
sex community and like sex workers in
general they just get way too much hate
and it needs to stop
you've had romantic part steady
boyfriends yes but I'm just not ready to
commit you know
I'm just looking for like Mr Mr Mr Right
and I actually I do have my partners my
sex partners but they know like hey back
it up it's like you know you're not
putting a ring on this you know what I
mean because them I love them but I know
they're not the one for me
what's your favorite kind of guy
I like Latino tattoos
um I like a man that knows how to you
know I like a hard-working man and I do
still date guys that are in the Trap I
still do like guys like that because I
feel like they get me but that's why you
know now those might be my sex partners
now but I'm looking for my Mr right and
don't get me wrong I also really do like
Frat Boys and preppy boys and stuff like
that like I wouldn't mind me a CEO for
marriage and that's when I'm kind of
like aiming more towards right now
so you're kind of a gold digger a gold
digger but I want I'm I am planning on
retiring from you know just all my
addictions soon and just interchanging
it with something else which that
addiction would be being a mother so I
want someone who can actually provide
for me and be a good man and I don't
have to worry you think
yes because oh my God like going to like
the soccer practices and stuff and just
like being like Oh my God like I don't
know it's just I watch videos on YouTube
and like moms like they live such a
hectic lifestyle and they always got
something going on so I feel like that
could be me
okay I hope that I hope that works yeah
um what's what's the wildest your sexual
escapades they've gotten
what's that well I mean like do you like
standard vanilla sex or do you like um
types of ways you know I'm definitely
not one for threesomes or any of that
which does make it sound more vanilla
but that's just because I don't like to
share I like to be the main center of
attention at all times but I mean wild
stuff I mean I I like to do everything
it's like I don't I'm not having guys
time me up or nothing like that though
and your your partners understand your
they understand and like honestly look
at me they're not gonna argue you know
they just like that I'm still like I'm
there for them and it's kind of like I
have forearm rotation right now so if
one's not ready for me in the morning or
one's not ready for me in the afternoon
it's like pack it up goodbye it kind of
revolves around yeah it does it does but
I can I can juggle you know like the
thing about sex is you can have it
anywhere in bathrooms public places cars
so if if I want it right now I could
call somebody up outside the studio and
say come in the car real quick you know
get it done five minutes and I'm not
assuming that you're Partners before you
have in rotation are just guys that are
taking advantage of somebody who will
get them laid but do you ever feel like
you're just
kind of being taken advantage of
um I feel like I'm taking advantage of
them to be honest because I just use and
abuse them for sex and they'll be like I
love you
yeah and you know that's the thing is a
lot of a lot of people do think that
they're like oh my God that girl she's
just getting Advantage taking advantage
of her sex but if I'm telling these men
I don't want nothing to do with you
besides sex then we are you know I'm
really taking advantage of them because
they're like I love you I want something
more and I'm like back it up what do you
think addictions stem from I mean why
why are you such an adrenaline junkie I
don't know I just think it's a type of
people's personalities you know like you
said earlier addiction can stem from
trauma addiction can stem from this but
to me
my addiction makes me happy so
I know a lot of people out here doing
hair when their addiction makes them
happy so why change it why quit it if it
makes you happy
and emotionally you would describe
yourself as having a hundred percent
really yeah I feel I really do because I
know what I want and I set boundaries
for what I want so
yeah you never feel lonely I don't feel
lonely because if I felt lonely I would
just call one of the Forum rotation and
say come come cuddle and that's
and that's satisfying yeah satisfying
they came cuddled I'm good
what's your biggest fear
um my biggest fear
I don't really have any fears like I
don't know my biggest fear but none of
your four guys are ready are available
tomorrow
oh they're not on Tinder oh come on sex
is the most accessible that's why you
know especially for a female yeah
especially for a female sex is so
accessible I mean just get on Tinder
real quick and that that has never
happened before they know I might I
might as well just put them all in a
group chat and we should start making a
schedule at this point
do you think if you fell in love with
somebody and you were going to settle
down you'd be able to
be monogamous oh 100 but they would have
to be on the same level as me because I
only I used to take five days off a
month when I'm menstruating but one of
my men who's in rotation he's a freak he
doesn't care so I don't even take days
off now so I need a guy that you know
it's not even like oh he has to be a sex
addict or anything because I'm just
asking for a couple times today a day
you know I'm not asking for anything
crazy and I'm asking specifically in the
morning because it's like my coffee
so it's your coffee yeah
and your partners some of them are
probably sex addicts too
I mean I guess you could say but I know
most of them all guys might be yeah all
you know I feel like everybody in
general is a sex addict everybody gets
horny
you could be right you could be right
do you have any regrets in your life
um I don't have any regrets because
with everything that I've done and did
in my life I feel like it's made me who
I am today and you're nothing without
trials and tribulation so
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
the most important lesson I learned I
learned or give up you know
always chase your dreams and don't let
you know people try to put you in a
corner you know they they used to call
me EBT baby because I was on food stamps
and they said I would never amount to
nothing well I have an Amex now so I did
amount to something you get a lot of
judgment from like your friends
um no I mean honestly they're just
haters anyone who hates on me for having
sex is probably needs to get laid
themselves to be honest because
someone's sex life is not something that
should be on display for anybody to
argue about disagree about it's just
that's something personal between that
person and their Partners so people
really need to stop being so nosy and
like listen I'm all for like tea and
drama and everything but people who
judge people sex life just uh it just
makes no sense yeah I think you're right
they just don't have a lot of sex that's
what it comes down to
you think most Americans are uptight
about sex
um yeah I think so
um people act like it's such a bad thing
you know and I'm like I said I'm a
Christian Catholic so
I am conservative and I am religious and
you would think that someone's so
religious I go to church on Sundays you
know but right after I'm having sex and
right before I had sex and I'm not
married you know so you would think oh
wow you know so Unholy but no God loves
me so at the end of the day if Jesus
loves you that's all that matters
and you're practicing safe sex oh of
course all the time I'm not ready for a
baby or any diseases hmm
is anything like that happen before
actually no I'm very clean good for you
yes
so you'll you'll meet your partners
online sometimes or where do you find
them yes
um like I told you guys before I used to
go on Kick this you know messenger app
when I was about 13 and I was in the
singers um single smokers group on there
but I also before that I was a cigarette
addict so I would go in all types of
groups trying to just find somebody who
can't Supply me with cigarettes and I
ended up going into a Newport singles
Group which I thought it meant Newport
menthols but it actually meant Newport
Virginia
and I met a guy on there and he ended up
getting me a bus ticket I think I was
about 15 or 16 and he got me a bus
ticket to Virginia and he lived in a
trailer park over there and he was
really nice but he didn't even have any
cigarettes really I mean he just had
meth
but we ended up actually it was like
kind of he was like kind of like my
first boyfriend like I really actually
like felt The Vibes with him
how old is he
um I think he was 32. you were 15. yeah
but I mean nobody even like I didn't
know that was not that not normal back
then so like nobody ever said like how
old were you when you first started
having sex like 13 13. yeah that's when
like kit came around Kik is where a lot
of you know people like me and people my
age that's where they found their like
significant other at the time and there
was also um this website called tagged
and there was a lot of men on there
and I mean I would meet like you know
you were asked me earlier if I ever
thought about prostitution well sex back
then was very transactional like there
was literally a guy who took me he spent
his food stamps on me at Kroger's and
got me a rotisserie chicken for oral sex
so yeah I've done a lot of things for I
guess I've done sexual things for
monetary game of course
what would you like to eat in five years
what do you think in five years I want
to be married I want to have um you know
a child I want to be successful
um I feel like I'm already successful
because I'm alive I'm glowing and you
know
I mean so yeah
I'm pretty content with your with your
lifestyle yeah but I can always do
better so
Diamond thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you wish you lots of
luck and have lots of fun thank you
thanks